karneval haben fluglinien freude da mein
letztes video zu dem thema so mega gut
ankam dachte ich nun schauen wir uns
heute mal wieder einige lustige online
school feld an
[Musik]
wir gerade sehen konntet wurde der
schüler namens benjamin während des
online unterrichts entführt und so
reagiert sein lehrer auf deutsch
übersetzt benjamin wurde gerade von
seinen mitbewohnern entfernt war gefragt
ein schüler seine lehrerin ob es okay
ist dass er während des unterrichts ein
bisschen etwas ist allerdings erlaubt
die lehrerin nur leichte snacks
[Musik]
die lehrerin am ende vor allem autos so
was denkt ihr was das ist ein buffet
aber das beste war der hund hier oben
eigentlich im nächsten oder in school
waren die video anzeigen von den zwei
personen übereinander so angeordnet dass
die obere personen relativ weit unten
angezeigt wurde und bei der unteren
person oben ein ich zeige ja einfach
dann wissen was ich meine
[Musik]
sowas kann nur während des online
unterrichts passiert
einfach im märz während des unterrichts
da wir gerade gesehen habe wurde hier
wieder eine person entführt es wird
vermutlich ein krank sein
allerdings reagiert der lehrer auch hier
ziemlich wird sich
wir haben mir die augen zu wir sehen
dass ich so ist müssen wir wirklich die
polizei anrufen und jetzt orleans
gefällt ist allerdings ein absoluter
favorit im heutigen video und zwar
schläft eine person einfach ein ist so
witzig wie die anderen reagieren
[Musik]
da kommt sogar die praktische art und
schreit ihr die dort
[Musik]
wie
das gemacht fand übrigens
dabei aufgefallen dass ein fun fact in
90 der fälle überhaupt nicht witzig ist
er hat gerade einen zaubertrick gemacht
vw ist wahrscheinlich wir das gemacht
hat gehe ich habe ich das gemacht habe
[Musik]
machen wir nun allerdings ganz gesittet
weiter mit dem nächsten neun games was
ist ein kranker live heck den ihr euch
auch merken solltet und immer parat
haben solltet wenn demnächst das online
school in wieder losgeht
sie wusste nicht die antwort auf die
frage des lehrers und hat deswegen
einfach eine ton datei mit dem handy
abgespielt wo eine schlechte verbindung
simuliert 777 simbabwe ein land in
afrika
hat niemand gesehen
[Musik]
fun fact übrigens wieder überhaupt nicht
witzig aber ich habe mir das bei tip top
10 mal angucken müssen um zu verstehen
was daran wird sich jetzt hier findet
auch eine online class viasuisse stadt
und die sache ist dass maddie sich wohl
auf einer party befindet währenddessen
allerdings an der online glas teilnimmt
aber vergessen hat ihr mikrofon auf
stumm zu stellen deswegen rasten ihre
mitschüler und auch der lehrer jetzt
auch extrem aus
[Musik]
wer kennt sie nicht am nächsten oder in
school haben wir allerdings wieder eine
interessante unterhaltung zwischen zwei
schülern mit ihrem lehrer also ganz
kurze zusammenfassung vor ich was hier
bisher passierte es der lehrer sagt zu
justin und diese anderen person hey ihr
nervt ich reporter euch da ich an die
schulleitung reporten der gebrauch zu
machen was gespielt jetzt entschuldigen
sich die beiden störenfriede allerdings
also justins entschuldigung ist halt hey
du mir leid ich versuchen nutzen lernen
die andere person hat dann auch eine
ganz kreative entschuldigung
dann kommt allerdings der lehrer der
lehrer den online unterricht in drei
sekunden beenden wenn die leute nicht
ruhig sind normalerweise hält man an die
fresse allerdings sind die beiden da
anderer meinung
[Musik]
er sagt einfach zu seinem leser dass er
ruhig sein soll weil er dem lehrer ja
nur helfen will
am ende wird das nun candlesticks
intensiv dass er nach den teils pieper
sie hat vergessen ihre kamera
auszustellen und es währenddessen auf
toilette gegangen
[Musik]
draußen stellen
vor allem dann auf dem klo oder nackt
[Musik]
der lehrer sagt dann vor allem let's
make sure every body has closed also auf
deutsch übersetzt hey lass uns beim
nächsten mal bitte sicherstellen dass
jeder auch klamotten an hat falls ihr
noch klamotten brauchen solltet meine
lieben freunde
wir haben zwei jungs vergessen die
mikrofone auszustellen unterhalten sich
während des online unterricht sogar
mädels dann fällt es allerdings den
leuten aus und leider war von einem der
beiden jungs auch seine freundin mit dem
xoom das ist unangenehm was auch
unangenehm ist es wenn man während des
meetings einfach ein schläft und
schnarcht
du hast dich an wie darf weder im
vorletzten online school für heute
möchte ein lehrer seinen schülern
freundlicherweise demonstrieren wie
schwarzer sand aussieht er vergisst
dabei allerdings die gesetze der
schwerkraft
[Musik]
eine tastatur macht jetzt ganz andere
geräusche werden allerdings zum letzten
nonnen school fällt fürs heutige video
und wenn bei euch demnächst wieder der
zoom unterricht losgehen sollte dann
könnt ihr euch zumindest hier auf wieder
freuen
sie macht einfach eine maske während
ihres online unterricht sehr genau sieht
die während der videoaufnahme plötzlich
eine maske machen würde
anders stellt euch das heutige jetzt
allerdings auch werden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch die sonne ist
grillfest gefallen haben das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter media und abonniert
main kanal im letzten video hab ich das
auch schon gesagt und seitdem haben mehr
leute meinen kanal nicht abonniert also
komplett gegenteiligen effekt gebracht
ich finde das auch dann blöd
[Musik]